public hearings are set to start in the
house impeachment inquiry that's gonna
be this week and Democrats are pushing
back against witnesses that Republicans
want to testify GOP members want to
question hunter Biden son of former Vice
President Joe Biden about corruption in
Ukraine Democrats say that has nothing
to do with the accusation from several
officials that the president withheld
military aid and pushed Ukraine to
investigate the Biden's and other
Democrats Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill for us so Nancy good morning what's
going on here well here's the list Tony
of the Republicans wish list if you will
prefered witnesses for this week's
public hearings there are nine names on
the list as you mentioned one of them is
hunter Biden who sat on the board of a
Ukrainian energy company Republicans say
they also want to hear from another
former board member as well as a former
DNC staffer neither of whom were
mentioned in the partial transcript of
the call with Ukraine's president or by
any other witnesses but this is part of
the Republican strategy they want to
call witnesses who they feel would
bolster their argument the president
Trump was simply trying to investigate
corruption in Ukraine they also want to
bring attention back to claims about
hunter Biden's work in Ukraine though
there has been no evidence of any
wrongdoing there House Intelligence
Chairman Adam Schiff said that he would
evaluate the list but that he would not
allow these hearings to become quote
sham investigations into the Biden's or
debunked conspiracy theories Democrats
have scheduled public hearings with
several witnesses who have already
described behind closed doors what they
said was a pressure campaign in Ukraine
in these close to our testimonies it all
begins on Wednesday with the top US
diplomat to Ukraine bill Taylor he has
said that his clear understanding was
that military aid to Ukraine would not
be released until Ukraine agreed to
investigate the Biden's and of course
we'll have special coverage of that
hearing but Nancy 4:00 this morning
we've just gotten word that another
house Republican won't be seeking
re-election next year what can you tell
us that's right New York's Peter King
has announced that he is going to be
retiring after 14
terms in Congress he says that this
wasn't an easy decision but that he
wants to spend more time with his kids
and his grandkids he did say that before
he goes he will vote against impeaching
the president he will also he said
support the president's bid for
re-election now King is a popular
congressman he is a fixture on TV so
he's pretty well-known up in New York
and around the country but it's not that
easy being in the minority party and so
he becomes the 17th House Republican to
announce he will not be seeking
re-election meaning there's gonna be a
lot of toss-up seats come 2020 all right
Nancy thank you very much